Democrats in Congress are demanding
Attorney General William bar deliver the
Mullah report by April the second but it
will be weeks not days before Bar comes
up with a version that can be made
public and while fighting over what is
in that version will continue president
Trump has a theory on where the
investigation began correspondent Kevin
cork reports tonight from the White
House in astonishing theory by President
Trump today on Capitol Hill that the
genesis of the Russia investigation and
subsequent Muller probe may have been
the work of the Obama White House
president's concern mirrors that of some
Republicans in Congress many of whom
believe that the basis of the
investigation deserves a much closer
look and perhaps its own special counsel
but far Republicans want to get to the
bottom of how things began Democrats
today said they want to more closely
inspect the probes finished product and
they wanted by their April 2nd deadline
or else we have a subpoena power and
frankly I don't see anything in the
special council's regulations that would
prohibit the Attorney General bar from
releasing it a four-page summary that
may be colored by the Attorney General's
personal views is not adequate the
American people need to see the whole
report sources tell Fox News that the
Attorney General believes it will take
weeks and not months to get a version of
the report to Capitol Hill while Schiff
and fellow Democrats want to see the
full report
Republicans want shift to resign from
his post on the House Intelligence
Committee in part because of his
repeated claims that evidence of
collusion with the Russians was in plain
sight and that at least according to the
special counsel turned out to be false
I think Adam Schiff should step down as
the chairman of the House Intelligence
this credible
evidence that he had seen and that he
had verified and after a two-year
lengthy investigation by a very
respected you know prosecutor we have no
evidence of collusion as you can imagine
John Green is not alone in his calls for
shift to resign California congressman
Adam Schiff could be on the way out
should be on the way out says Kevin
McCarthy maybe not could but certainly
he wants him to give up the chairmanship
so does Kellyanne Conway the senior
advisor to the president here at the
White House but as you can imagine he's
not giving up that post anytime soon
John know somehow I think that Adam
Schiff is not paying much attention for
those calls for him to resign Kevin
Clark at the White House tonight thanks
Kevin you've been